READINESS AT RISK.
FRED PLEITGEN IS "OUT FRONT" IN
MOSCOW WITH THE VERY LATEST ON
THE GROUND THERE.
>> Reporter: RUSSIA CONTINUING
TO HIT UKRAINE'S TOWNS AND
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE ONCE AGAIN
FIRING DOZENS OF ROCKETS AND
MISSILES LEAVING MILLIONS
WITHOUT POWER OR HEAT AS WINTER
HAS CLEARLY ARRIVED.
AND THE KREMLIN MAKING CLEAR ITS
ARIEL BLITZ WON'T STOP.
THE SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION
CONTINUES, THE KREMLIN SPOKESMAN
SAYS, AND ITS CONTINUATION DOES
NOT DEPEND ON CLIMATIC
LOCATIONS.
MOSCOW IS TRYING TO FREEZE
UKRAINE INTO SUBMISSION.
THEY'RE CALLING THE GENERAL IN
CHARGE OF THE WAR TO STEP UP THE
ATTACKS ON THE ENERGY SECTOR.
>> Translator: I APPEAL TO ARMY
GENERAL, A HERO OF RUSSIA.
I ASK YOU TO COMPLETE THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE OF UKRAINE.
>> Reporter: THE RUSSIANS ACCUSE
UKRAINE OF TRYING TO ORCHESTRATE
A PROVOCATION AFTER NATO
GOVERNMENTS SAY A MISSILE THAT
LANDED IN POLAND WAS PROBABLY
FIRED FROM UKRAINIAN TERRITORY
EVEN AS THE U.S. AND ITS ALLIES
SAY RUSSIA BEARS THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY.
MOSCOW IS BUCKLING UNDER
SANCTIONS.
THE COUNTRY IS OFFICIALLY IN
RECESSION.
WHILE PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
CALLED ON RUSSIAN COMPANIES TO
HELP VETERANS AND PENSIONERS,
EVEN ON STATE MEDIA A MEMBER
WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> Translator: WHAT WILL WE
DRIVE?
WE HAVE NOTHING TO DRIVE.
ARE WE GOING TO DRIVE RAIL CARS?
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
LET'S NATIONALIZE EVERYTHING.
WHAT WILL WE DRIVE?
HOW WILL WE MAKE PHONE CALLS?
WHAT WILL WE DO?
>> Reporter: IN MANY AREAS THAT
RUSSIA HAS ILLEGALLY ANNEXED,
THE ISSUES ARE MORE.
MANY RESIDENTS ARE SQUATTING IN
THE RUINS AND STRUGGLING TO GET
BY.
>> Translator: WHAT HAVE I
TURNED INTO?
I'M A BAG LADY.
I DON'T LIKE MYSELF ANYMORE
BECAUSE OF HOW I LOOKED.
I NEVER LOOKED LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: HOPE IS HARD TO
COME BY FOR THE FOLKS HERE AS
THE TOUGHEST WINTER MONTHS STILL
LIE AHEAD.
>> Reporter: ERIN, IT'S ALREADY
EXTREMELY COLD IN PARTS OF
UKRAINE AND EASTERN EUROPE.
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THE
RUSSIANS HAVE SAID IS THEY CLAIM
THE STRIKES THEY ARE CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING ARE H